this is a production of Cornell
University
okay hello there my name is Carl mentee
with the Cornell turfgrass program and
today I'm gonna walk everyone through
how to use our turf and landscape weed
ID tool and this is an online resource
that dr. Jenny Cao - here at Cornell our
weed scientists developed she's got a
lot of great help over the years from
people like grant Thompson Reagan ette
Leah Butler Jones has most recently but
a lot of work into this website so today
what I want to do is just walk everybody
through how to use the website and we're
gonna do that with a weed I went out and
found this morning so it's early April
I'm out in the backyard and found this
weed I'm gonna throw it up here in the
top right hand corner of the screen and
we're just gonna go ahead and use the
website and try and figure out what this
weed is so to start you know I just
typed in Cornell weed ID on Google and
first thing that pops up is our website
so I'm gonna go ahead and click on that
and we got our first decision here right
so is it a grass leg or broadleaf weed
like so you know pretty obviously as you
can see up here this looks like a
broadleaf weed I'm just gonna go ahead
and click that so now this brings me to
kind of the main screen here I can see
I've got a hundred and eighteen results
and here's you know you can see each
weed the name and just a general picture
there so you know if I wanted to I could
go and click on each one of these and
see if it looks like my weed but really
what I'm gonna use is this stuff on the
left-hand side of the screen here all
these traits that are gonna help me
whittle down what what weed it is so
when I'm looking at this weed and you
may or may not be able to see it up here
in the top right but I see a lot of
hairiness and fuzziness and the leaf so
I'm gonna see if any one of these
characteristics over here on the Left
describes that so scroll down and and
here's where I where I'm looking tactile
so I see smooth fuzzy and rough and
that's that fuzzy texture is definitely
what I'm what I'm seeing on my weed so
I'm gonna click on that and now we've
we've narrowed things down so we got
from 118 to walk to only 16
um so again I could go ahead and scroll
through all these and see what they if
they match my weed but I'm gonna go one
more step and the stature thing looks
like a trade I can narrow things down
with and you know based on what I saw
outside spreading is the trade it's got
click on that and now we're down to
three so I can look at these and and I
think one of these looks tough
definitely like my weed but let me check
some other ones first common mallow so
it's got some of the traits I selected
but definitely doesn't look like my weed
right the leaf shape isn't quite right
yellow hawk weed okay you know I'm not
seeing that in my weed definitely
definitely not like my we'd finally
Mouse here chick weed okay
so as I think everybody can see this is
uh it's got the hairiness on there
definitely resembles what I've got
and so each weed on the website has
multiple pictures so dr. Kenneth Ann and
her team have done a really good job of
putting in multiple pictures here you
can see the seed size if you want to get
really specific what it looks like it's
a seedling so you know there is pretty
quick way to do identify Mouse your
chick weed and I can go down here some
information on no lifecycle and traits
and some identifying characteristics and
then of course I can also look at
controls right so I click on that tab I
scroll down here and I've got control
options so conventional pesticides I
think these are New York specific so if
we don't have a certain website label in
New York it's not gonna be on here but
you've got those and then you've got
reduced risk and minimum risk options -
so for K through 12 managers K through
12 Grounds managers here in New York
they have restrictions on conventional
pesticide use so for most cases they're
limited to these reduced or minimum risk
options so you know that's a that's a
great way to use this tool it gets you
to a screen you can identify your weed
and you can learn a little bit more
about things one more thing I like and
it's a new feature on this website is
the pesticide free management
so this is something alia Butler Jones
has worked a lot on recently again
geared towards our K through 12 managers
where they've got kind of these unique
situations fence lines gravels mulch
areas right so we can go in here and we
can learn about non pesticide ways to to
control weeds in these areas so it gives
you options for mechanical control
barriers how you're gonna set up that
fence line in a way that's gonna allow
you to manage those weeds better and
more efficiently thermal weeding
something we've studied here at our turf
grass program thermal weeding right so
let's burn those plants up here's some
options things to think about so you
know a great addition to this website I
think has been this pesticide free
management area again these are kind of
problem areas where you know you're
gonna think about non non pesticide
products and their control options so
that's a quick overview of the turf and
landscape weed ID website I hope
everyone found that useful and and
hopefully you can keep this place
bookmarked in your browser now I did it
on the computer you can of course do it
on your phone too so I always available
if you're out in the field and looking
to do something out there so I hope
everyone has found this helpful and
thanks for watching this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu